often
science
[Music]
meet
people from our internet audience asking
what's the language okay I should switch
that's right um so um and and we we
didn't choose just a a a very easy topic
right so we so since he just joined uh
maybe 2020
then right before the the pandemic so we
said okay you do the talk about 10 years
of operating um machine learning trip
applications at BL yond so he had to
soak up all the knowledge of the experts
and I hope you got it all of it because
now you have to present it so
[Applause]
welcome okay so welcome to my talk
operating an a IML driven product at
scale for 10 plus years and I will just
start copying the season speaker with
saying uh I will do talks from
now um so let's uh hop right into it um
this talk will not be about data science
as or data scientists as a uh as a focus
but we will shine the spotlight on the
other teams that are enabling us to run
our systems and our product as we do and
I will start with a small little about
of about us just a few slides to um uh
show to you why we are or what enables
us to be able to be in the position to
speak about this the first
place so we here at be Yonder The V
venue we are the company that is uh uh
presenting the venue today um we are in
the Dem in the supply chain sector and
our mission is the automation of the
supply chain and uh I'm data scientist
as Sebastian just introduced me and I'm
from the lde the Luminate demand Edge uh
team and what we are doing is we are
providing uh for the retail sector um
demand forecast so we have the supply
chain from the supplier to the
distribution centers to the actual
stores and our um solution the demand
Edge is um giving giving the the
customers the entire um retailers uh
with their Global or Regional uh uh
structures we are giving them the or
providing them the forecast which uh
products will be sold uh in in the
source at at what amounts and uh we are
running all of this um fully
automated um or um AI solution fully
automated um with some key kpis I will
come back to these later but uh just to
to grasp the scale which is what we are
talking about today is that our systems
or largest customer system can run 500
million forecasts in 10 minutes which is
relevant to us because the customers
expect uh their forecast for the large
organization
every night and the sooner that we get
the forecast out to the customer the
better because they can start ordering
sooner and they will not run into um
into uh restocking um issues uh because
in the supply chain the um the if you
are uh delayed at the very end you will
get um like enhanced effects to to as we
said uh so as we' seen earlier we you
will get uh more delays to to the left
side because each and every single um
Link in the chain will pass the um the
problems through and uh just the the
scale of the entire system so across all
of our systems this is a little bit of a
dated number from 2022 but uh every
quarter we are running uh then we have
grown since then but we have run 7
trillion predictions uh in one quarter
so um yeah like our product is is
supplying lot of uh known names and we
are talking today about um how we get
how we ended up here and uh What uh
steps in the way at what steps in in in
in the way here we standed up the
mountain but first the last slide about
our company so we have started very um
adjacent to the car University in a
small company called ft physics and
technology and uh from that was born the
German company BL Yonder uh we were
acquired right before I actually joined
so in 2019 by a large company named jda
it's about or back then it was around
5,000 employees and uh yeah then we
played some unu reverse card and uh
actually we acquired them like the 200
people up uh not really but yeah
nowadays we are penasonic
owned but a separate uh organization
subsidiary okay but now let's get into
the talk uh having talked about the the
numbers uh push them first so our
success journey and our success
recipe so as many other small companies
I said we started small uh the first
objective is winning some customers
providing them some custom Solutions uh
and without really having an identity
yet so just uh custom has a problem you
Pro provide a solution to solve the
problem and growing while growing the
the customer uh the solution needs to
start to scale so you are trying to
consolidate some custom Solutions and um
in the end you're trying to build a
product Identity or a stage product
identity but at this uh some point when
you really start um hitting some
problems and you really start to have to
scale your um your company because your
name gets known and more and more
customers will try to to get your
Solutions because you're getting values
to to their competitors you really have
to push and start to establish a clear
identity for your product and this is
something we are established in our in
our segment and uh the the core
um uh the the the core ingredient in our
recipe um has turned out that to be that
we are operating our system very close
to the data scientist so many other
companies that are starting to scale the
solution we have a data science team and
some uh um some operations team and
these are separated so you will you
start to move the the data away from the
scientists so um uh sooner or later um
those companies run into issues where
the the scientists are too far from the
data so we have actually our um success
recipe I said is uh we as the data
science team are actually operating the
entire system uh as the data science
team so I as a data scientist am uh
developing my solution or the the um the
stories the uh the new
um the new project there the new um
enhancements and I I get it all the way
to production um which is in which is um
decreasing the um uh the the time that
we uh the turnaround time of uh um
recognizing errors um we are having fast
iteration Cycles working right on the
data and uh it improves us or gives us
the ability to to uh ship our
improvements timely because we are
directly um pushing our um our changes
to to production so the the big
requirements is mainly in time so um
when we are operating our systems we
cannot develop them so the the two big
branches are on the one side that we
have to um be able to operate the uh to
develop new systems un unimpaired by the
operations so we have to decrease the
amount of time we are spending our
operations on the other side talk part
of the um operation is also the customer
uh interaction so uh by scaling down the
uh the need for the customer to interact
with us and the need for us to interact
with our systems we can focus more on
the development of our software so from
from here on I will focus on the um uh
segment automation custom customer
enablement and
standardization of course
standardization um in for so starting
with automation um our entire system is
running completely automated from A to Z
so if nothing goes wrong we do not have
at any point any um need to to interact
with the system after we have configur
the system for the given customer um we
have complet um alerting separately for
the def team and also for under our
um our support teams underneath um
to to be able to to operate the system
at scale um our deployment is completely
automated and uh we also have automated
our entire development process and I
will show this
later um for for the section of customer
enablement uh we have invested a lot in
a powerful AI assisting uh UI assist
assisting us um data
scientists um
by giving the customer the ability to
access their data directly
automated um understand the forecast
analyze the quality of the forecast
themselves and they can even interact
with the forecast we are um giving them
by issuing overrides for example so the
customer we we are enabling the customer
to not have to interact with us but to
um actually um have a faster way to to
interact with their with our predictions
themselves with our powerful UI and the
most important thing that our UI is
providing us as a as a development team
in the end is uh if there is a problem
with the system that the customer really
has to ask us about because it is the
problem in the model it serves as one um
Central interface for both the customer
to be able to to send or to show us what
is the problem and us to report back to
them and also share for example a link
to our UI with a new analysis to share
them uh what they are misconstruing
about the situation or to give them
additional information of what is
actually wrong so the we we had a lot of
problems in in the past where the
customers like every customer has in
different systems so they're just
sending some CSV file and you have to
spend hours to first get what they
actually going or getting to getting at
before having being able to to um to
start with your analysis in the first
place so this is why our powerful AI is
on core um uh part in the in the chain
for us uh to be able to operate our
systems and then the the last um uh the
last big sector is standardization of
course like uh custom Solutions cannot
be operated as scale so um I will be
talking again about features
Technologies and our powerful platform
which is actually a big part of enabling
us to operate and develop at the same
time so let's just go a little bit over
this so you can see we actually have
proof that we started out as a very
small company so um we started out with
this as our back end with our custom
Solutions we grew and um one big problem
with growing and scaling a um a product
that has started with custom solution is
that the the customers also got some
custom features and at some point you're
consolidating your software and uh
you're still providing um compatibility
to all these custom features because the
customer still wants it but at some
point you will not be able to scale this
anymore so there there will be a a point
in time where you have to have built
enough trust with the customer to um be
able to discontinue some features and uh
compare tell them uh to to take the step
with you by providing them a lot of uh
diff or a lot of value on other sides
with the improvements that uh you will
make to the system where where while you
uh once you be you are able to to scale
the system on the other hand on the
other
side then the the next very or one of
the very Central um enablers for us to
be able as data scientists to be able to
operate our own system systems is our
proprietary platform um so we we are
calling it Stratosphere which is started
out as we have seen before with just
some some PCS taped together in the
basement and very uh very uh early we
started scaling so as again in this
basement there were we set up our own
calculating
resources um and finally we we started
to to Microsoft Azure but uh we as data
scientists we do not actually have to um
to care or to um to to interact with
Azure at all because we are interacting
with our own proprietary platform which
is um abstracting resources uh in
standardized ways that we can plan our
processes around and uh one big thing is
that uh even Azure has sometimes
problems has clusters going down
has wide ranging problems that um can be
solved if you have a lot of um expertise
uh with with handing these problems and
uh this one single platform enables us
to um as data scientists not have the
knowledge have to have the knowledge to
to handle these platform or these um
resource uh incidents because we have a
different uh team that we can uh hand
these problems to while still being able
to to push forward with iterating upon
the uh the machine learning model and
this and operate our systems in the on
on the other hand on the other side um
so the platform is one of the of the
biggest reasons why we as a data science
team can actually operate our um our um
software at the same time um because
this is a lot of uh of uh knowledge and
a lot of expertise that we can just hand
to this team uh also it provides us a
lot of Economics of scale uh because I
said uh like right now um it started out
with lde being one of the of the largest
um products on on this platform and
there were a lot of improvements um on
and requirements that that have been
implemented and uh served to us which is
now also providing the same benefits to
new prod products in the in the company
that are currently being migrated onto
this platform
um the the last uh or the next big
reason why we have our own platform is
as coming back to the two numbers before
if we can run 500 million um predictions
on one system in 10 minutes this means
that we can almost run our entire
workload on one system but uh we have a
lot of different systems for different
customers deployed at the same time so
um the the resource demand that we have
as we said we are calculating during the
uh during the night time is very spiky
and very Spar so uh Stratosphere
actually gives us the opport the ability
to um pull these resources and
distribute and balance these resources
across our Computing
workloads that we again as as data
science team do not have to care about
this is something that is provided out
of the box by our PL
team
okay so uh as said again because the we
are talking about the last 10 years um
there has to be there has been quite
some iteration and just like a little
bit little visualization where where the
platform has come from a move two so we
can see that it actually looks
dated and it does the next situation so
right now we are on Stratosphere 10 this
is somewhere in between and um it still
looks dated but uh we can actually see
if we look U at the at the format that
we already have some um some project and
some uh uh recognizable uh systems
running which is something that the the
latest version also it looks a little
bit better now it looks a little bit
less dated and a lot of things have
changed a lot of uh capabilities has
been added but at the in the end uh the
the um we have grown with the platform
the platform has grown with us and
enabled us to run our processes as we
desire and both uh the back end and
statosphere
have uh progressed in time even
visually um a very small slide uh just
to mention coming back to what Peter
said at the very um at the very start of
this um event uh that we are doing data
science since it was called statistics
so back then it wasn't actually python
wasn't necessarily the standard to uh to
solve these problems so uh during the
years we had to to migrate from s
implemented basic versions of pandas and
um and dusk for example or spark
distributed uh um implementations of of
Frameworks that are given today but that
have not uh existed back in the day so
this is a lot uh a big thing that you
have to adapt to the shifting technology
technological landscape at all
times and uh another story that is
happening right now is that at some
point du because we have uh all of these
Sagen workloads especially in our uh
evaluation um processes because I said
we we can run actually run our
evaluations on all customer systems so
if we run a a global evaluation that
there's a lot of systems that are quing
the data at the same time so we in the
in the past coming from or quering the
data exact directly from databases had
us uh impede our um development
processes so in the meantime we moved
away from carrying data from the
database but we actually U put the data
down to the to the file system in some
uh In Pockets or in um stalled in some
blob stores querying it from there had
us uh enabled us to to have more
parallel workload on these systems but
uh technology have moved forward and
right now we are running a um initiative
to move everything back to the database
again on snowflake so uh yeah like even
if you have a good solution at one point
the um uh the technological landscape is
Shifting and you have to keep up and
maybe even move back what you did
before um in terms of automation um this
is just some some some um uh screenshots
from airflow airflow is the service that
we are using to orchestrate all of our
um productive systems and um we actually
moved from the start like we started off
small as set and we had a lot of manual
triggers for a lot of processes and this
is now fully
automated um I mentioned it earlier but
uh nowadays we only have a initial
configuration effort for uh for new
customer systems and uh everything from
that on as long as there are no incident
situations is running from a to z
completely automated so from data
ingestion from the customer over us
managing the data running our trainings
or predictions to providing the data
back to the customer is running fully
running fully automated and uh
automation is just uh all like the
initial automation is first is just the
first step but we ran into a lot of
problems with uh actually managing the
uh this the incidents and the Systems
Failing so ever since we have um always
increased and expanded our um our
processes uh on and our system with
additional rares with some recovery some
U um process recovery so for example in
our training if the training is is
triggered here if it is failing in our
weight TK we actually have another loop
with some recovery function to trigger
it again to just try again because if
this is just uh some some fluke
happening if this is a networking
problem um the system will recover
itself um and we will it will decrease
the amount of interaction that we have
into the system if it can recover itself
and if everything goes goes south to to
put it like this we also have forb back
um mechanis M so the system is actually
able to uh to um provide a previously um
achieved uh predictions to the customer
in some fullback uh functions so um it
is taking pressure from assess the data
science teams science team as the
operating team to
act at the very time that the incident
is happening because we have fallback
functions covering um our our losses in
in some
cases now on to uh the uh like away from
the um operation part and onto the um
part that I mentioned that uh what what
uh is the uh is the advantage of having
the data very close to the um to the
data scientist uh it is our ability to
test all of our changes so every single
change that we can do can be run on any
customer system so if our like some some
customers have in the sales data very
different patters and others so some
customers have some um problems with
their um with their predictions that
others don't and uh if we design a
change to the model if we try to fix the
problem we can run with just uh the the
click on one button with a GitHub action
we can run the um the the test for the
system on some limited scopes with one
click on any system on all systems and
right uh behind
this we have a lot of uh reporting or
automated reporting so once we are
triggering our evaluation functions with
one click there will be hundreds of
pages of PDF reports um about these
changes what is the impact of my change
will automatically be uh
generated and um this is something we
have spent a lot of time perfecting and
uh this is something that is really
increasing our um our time to iterate
upon changes and uh really see in a very
short amount of time uh has my change
worked where has have other places like
uh in data science or with a with a
machine learning model if you change if
it change it at one point um it to say
that something is breaking on on another
side maybe so uh we have Global um
reports and um ranking of of error cases
where we can actually see
um yeah if something is breaking on one
side and we fixed it but uh it is
breaking more on the other side it will
be uh caught here and will be uh put to
our attention uh part of these reports
is also um this is an example where GL
yonda is currently saving Christmas so
uh Christmas is a very um is a very uh
tumultuous time for us because it's it's
one of the biggest events for many of
the of the retail customers and we can
see here um so a little bit of a legend
uh so this is just uh the the zoom in of
of
the uh effect we can see here but uh the
green dots is the sales that we are
trying to predict the Master state so
the problematic state was the orange
line and the candidate state is some is
the is the branch dat we have just
triggered our evaluation on we can see
here um directly after having pressed
one button that uh my change has worked
or my change has not worked and this is
on customer data on live data at real
time um also it's not just uh I said not
we cannot just evaluate one system
but uh fix I said fixing the or changing
the the the system at one point can have
very uh
harsh consequences for other customers
for example and uh this all of our um
evaluation mechanisms is also Global uh
to or can be Global if we trigger all
systems but we have also some meta
analysis uh reporting to see uh how does
how our changes are affecting the system
in all customers so we had to reduct the
customers but these are different
customer systems and different
comparisons uh from uh the main State
and your candidate Brown state for
example uh so going away from Automation
and uh um from our development cycle uh
over to um our UI side so the UI as as
mentioned earlier is is something we
have spent a lot of time and a lot of
effort uh um we put into it because at
some point in time or back in the in the
day uh sometimes there was a little bit
of a sentiment to to limit the amount of
data we want to show to the customer
because if the if the customer sees less
problems we have less uh service
requests or they are raising less issues
to us but uh this is something that we
really recognized that uh we um we had
to change
uh because um the the customers uh the
the uncertainty just ra Rose and they
they were um putting more and more
service requests out to us uh which was
limiting our ability to push the system
so forward so we went from some
notebooks uh some IPython notebook
analysis and some PDF analysis to a
fully automated UI system um we have now
reached a point where basically 80% of
what we are looking at in our internal
um tooling is also visible by the
customer and also represented on the UI
so we're really enabling the customer to
see that the the forecast to analyze the
forecast and to to gauge the the um the
quality of their forecast at the same
time and uh we have really recognized
that uh the customer understanding what
they getting with us and uh what um what
kind of issues is actually also coming
from their own data quality issues and
their own uh limitations uh of of the
data that is that they are sending to us
has really uh relieved a lot of pressure
from um incoming customer requests and
just the amount of of um of incidents
that the the customers were raising with
us so the the UI is not functioning
functioning not as an analysis tool just
for the um uh for for the customer as
well but since we have all this
capability um on the UI if the customer
is raising an an incident with uh with
some screenshot of our UI which is the
only as as I said earlier like the UI is
now a um the sole interface that we are
accepting for service requests because
we will not be looking at CSV files that
they are sending to us anymore so they
will send us a a screenshot of our UI
and because of the all these
capabilities most of the time we can
actually just go through the uh go
through the UI ourselves and already
respond with the um with with uh the the
problem that we are seeing uh without us
having to actually um go back to our
internal tooling and reconstructing the
situation and um yeah this has really
decreased the turnaround on our service
requests and then our um customer um
interactions a
lot um another big
thing another big thing is uh that the
UI is not only capable or the the
customer not only capable to to analyze
their um uh their problems on the UI or
their forecast but they are actually
also able to um to manipulate um the
forecast so we have the option this is
something that the customers were really
requiring from us that they want to have
the power to override a problem that
they are seeing because problems are
happening if you are putting out
billions of predictions um so we have as
part of the UI we have this override
service so the customer has the the
power to override everything uh I said
they the customer feels very strongly
about this and this is something that
they really want because it gives them
control but uh last year we actually run
ran a um a scientific um
uh
uh sorry we ran a test on whether the um
the overrides that the customer is
issuing is actually adding the value and
we have found that uh most of the time
when the customer is interacting with
the system they're actually making it
worse so uh it is something that the
customer really wants but in the end uh
this is probably something uh up to
debate in the future because uh it is a
Marge to to our Automation and our
systems working better than the experts
that are interacting with the system uh
afterwards and another very big um very
big Point uh for the the customer side
of operations uh alleviating a lot of
stress from us is having built a a um
customer support structure uh that is
interacting so um we came from a
position actually
uh even in the last three years when I
started I still had a sales force
account so we came from a position where
we were directly interacting with the
customer with their requests to building
an entire um support structure beneath
us with uh at the start uh script
scripted Solutions but we have really
started educating them and they are
really educating themselves as well to
uh fence off a lot of the incoming
requests with their expertise already as
well so again this is a large part of uh
operational um workload that we do not
have to content any with anymore as a
data scientist team so we are moving uh
more and more to to the state where we
are just reaping the rewards to of being
close to the data but not having the the
the draw a lot of the drawbacks anymore
that we saw in in the past from
operating it at the same
time okay and because it's in the title
we have to finish with successes
failures and learnings so um outright
successes is mainly as I said um the
platform this is something that we have
profited from from the very start and we
have never looked back and actually the
entire company so I said we have we have
been acquired by jda in the past and the
platform was already something that
existed then and more and more systems
in the entire big company now are moving
onto the platform so this is really a um
success story um then I said we have
never DED uh automation uh automating
all all of our systems so um this has
just been a success story from from the
start and um yeah the little bit of
standardization that I um mentioned but
there's a lot more of standardization
that we were conducting in the system so
these are just success stories and uh
yeah failures and learnings so um some
points where we uh in our journey where
we have stumbled up the hill um is first
um that we tried um the the the approach
of operating the system uh away from the
development teams and we have not uh
been able or it has hit a lot of um of
the um problems with uh impeding Us in
in going forward not being able to to
work on the data as closely for example
so this is something that is really a
big Point um I I want to bring to you
that this helped us a lot and this is
something that has a lot uh of of
learning in it um then as again um the
the first approach of uh fencing
information and uh some analysis tooling
away from the customer with the with the
fear of the customer overwhelming us
with seeing problems was completely the
wrong direction so we have made the the
um we have made the experience that
giving the customer more capabilities to
anal analyze the problems is actually
making it better because they can
educate themselves more and get more
adjusted to your system and what is uh
what is actually going wrong rather than
them just thinking something is going
wrong not having the information to
analyze um where where it's coming from
um then uh at the start uh the the in
insufficient um investment in the other
support structure
fencing or first filtering the data for
for the data science team is something
that we have iterated on a lot and is
now helping us a lot with not having to
uh to interact with the service requests
as development team anymore or as the
operating team and um yeah like in the
end uh at some points we have accepted
some uh some interactions with the
system but we have found out very fast
that uh full a
is the way to go so this is one of the
largest and uh last points that I want
to mention here so just a little bit of
of a of a finishing plug um yeah we are
currently really searching for data
Engineers data scientists and software
Engineers they want to expand upon our
our system upon uh expand our
automation improve our
forecasts and um we might not have the
fitting position on our career side but
Peter is happy to to just receive an
email from you so feel feel free to to
spam him a little
bit um yeah and that's all I have to say
[Applause]
today yeah thanks a lot for the talk I
would like to pass on
mhone are there any
questions was the Bigg deliver to a
store do you remember this
incident the good thing is I was never
really involved in those uh customer
projects so I was I was in the platform
from early on so and and I did a better
service so but yeah there we had some
incidents right so there was one which
was uh at some point fully packed with
beer so every floor
was it was a problem I don't I don't
exactly know what what a real issue was
it was a data problem from the customers
it
was but yeah it was a lot of
fear yeah but that's a good point I
think about supporting the
user so the input
data I can
the product so
the try to do is a lot of if you Auto
the system you also want to steal the
customer to focus on really things where
he can have a large impact and that's
where we are
using trying it out can be guide the
right exceptions so that the power us on
the customer side is guided to I don't
know high level deviations and and only
looks at stuff really can and that's
what we're trying out we also try um to
basically learn from from user
interactions this overrides analis we
have see okay they make it worse then we
try to give them hints and try to
separate the cases where they make
things worse to guide them again and say
in the past we have seen you have done
this and this and this it didn't help
maybe you shouldn't do it this time so
that's what we are trying
out we putting it on the marketing
slides that we are doing it in
production actually but still
any more questions over
there I have
question the Reas
Toof Yeah so basically we did an
analysis um technically it would have
all been
possible then we and they told us you go
to AWS direct competitor retailer will
never do business with you so AWS was
out and then we talk with Google and I
don't know if you have experience with
Google customer support so did you ever
got a real person on some Google issue
never yeah so Google sucks at customer
support and they also suck at Enterprise
customer support that was really the
reason for us this is
true
because YouTube to
Google engineers and I think also very
brilliant software that you can use
there but as an Enterprise customers
it's so hard to interact with them
because they always think they are the
only Geniuses in the planet this was
really a reason for us where Microsoft
coming from an Enterprise
software maybe not offering the best
cloud service today okay but really also
the support and you need this support if
you depend on a cloud provider you need
to get support there if you can't help
yourself that was back in the days one
of the reasons that to
go I can even over some years the CTO
back then was like yeah we wrote to AWS
they said here is 100,000 credits try it
out asure was like uh okay uh we send
you uh five developers over we fly them
in sit together with you they build it
with you uh and Google was we don't
understand the prices are on the home
page
so about so that's the difference and
probably that was the reason why was the
way to go
right uh there was
some
may a littleit specific but I was exper
this problem myself you said you can
power users by providing very powerful
UI check everything aspect of the model
that's all fine but at the same at the
same time you said you have
lightly build of your model and reques
huge resources consumption right and but
you something interactive like when
customer make a
change like how you is it is it a
problem for you or you just show the
current state of the
model and it's not direct
so I know it's a no it's fine yeah like
uh the way we are operating is that the
the um the the information that the UI
is operating on is cached and it's um it
is cached until the we are ingesting so
every run is first ingesting data and
make and seeing that the data is for the
Run for the next run um in a consist
state but everything that happens
between is is cached and is not fed to
the data or to to the um to the database
right away so uh when you make you can
uh add a lot of overrides and remove
overrides and
U interact with the UI uh and this it is
all just cached and it will then be um
transferred to a consistent State once
the backand system is running the next
time yeah customer not changing the
model it's only Chang it's it's it's all
the customers only overwriting
predictions so um the the model will Al
so in the back end the model will put
out the new forecast uh for the next uh
in the next run but if there's an
override active right now it will be it
will be overwritten when we write it
back to the customer so the the forecast
will actually in our systems will be
what the model is predicting but the
data that is sent back to the customer
will be what they over overrode in the
UI but the customer cannot trigger a
model rerun or something yes not
yet no no this is not coming like they
are very a strict schedule everything is
on very strict schedules and uh we are
also I think we got this a little bit
wrong um that we are not deploying every
day so the uh the training is actually
running on a much higher or larger time
scale than the predictors running so we
have actually very strict slas as I said
for the for the predict because the
customer is really
expecting his predictions now but the
fits can be running for up up to a week
so uh the we have some we have
versioning uh for so every fit this is
um is when the fit is completed we have
routines that activates the fit on for
the prediction but uh so it's a very
asynchronous work um uh process
yeah the
U it's powerful but it's more showing s
right so yes and that's makes it fast
right yes that PDF was before just
different format but now it's like maybe
better presented but it's still
precalculate Stace like that you update
the data and the customer can do with
this
picture
except dat for the next prediction
yes
exactly
[Music]
mention
so this was something was before my time
but as far as I understand so we have
all of our data that the customer is
sending that we're ingesting uh of
course we are storing it in the database
and I showed the um the slide I can yeah
okay I showed the slide where we had a
lot of systems running in one large
evaluation over basically all the
customers so uh we have our um our
processing clusters um processing the uh
the different steps of the model and all
of these operations are quing the data
from the database if this is the if if
this is your single software of Truth or
the point where you're carrying from and
uh when we triggered a lot of these
system at the same time um the the
bottleneck turned out to be the database
connection so the the database was not
keeping up with our demands for parallel
access to our data so what we did is or
what we figured out is that the blobster
access can actually be scaled a lot
better so we are qu we are building uh
we are calling those cubes so we are
quaring the data at the start of our um
our processes of our um we call De of
our processes we're caring the data we
are storing it on the blob store in
parket files so they are actually
underneath are just pandas data frames
in parket files and and um the access to
this data of the of the calculation
cluster uh was much more performant U
when we were quaring the data from these
blob stores and writing back to these
blob stores but um yeah I said uh this
has worked good for us but it also came
with some
challenges uh because we we have to to
synchronize the data all the time so we
have to synchronize it to the blob store
we have to synchronize it back to the
databases which is uh part of why we are
now moving mov to a more capable data
database system which is what snowflake
is going to provide to us now because
they are actually capable of providing
us the the parallelization that we are
needing um this is the reason why we are
moving over so we don't have to like a
part large part of St we don't have to
synchronize the data anymore to these um
between these representations so the key
is really horizontal scaling so
traditional database system you can't
scale hor onally they are one big
machine you can make the machine bigger
but at some point you overload it yeah
then came blob storage Technologies
where you suddenly have been able to
horizontal scale your access yeah data
was there once you could scale it with
thousands of computation clusters and I
think now snowflake has taken this to
the next level because the separated
storage from compute and basically you
can horizontally scale your compute what
they call virtual warehouses yeah spin
up as you like on demand on seconds
additional warehouses accessing the same
data um underneath so you have a
database system that now horizontally
scales and of course a database system
with transactions with schema management
and so all has Al also some benefits
yeah that you don't have if you run
direct park access on blob store unless
uh you build tooling on top of it
man yeah we can probably have one or two
talks about this alone maybe just to to
uh to to um talk about team structure so
actually um Peter someone he's coming
from the platform side so he's expert on
this but um our teams are organized we
have the platform as said which is
another team we have me and the data
science team but we also have an ml
engineering team right next to us so
this is actually something that I I'm
not interacting a lot with because this
is responsibility of the M Engineering
team which is also uh allowing us uh
another part of allowing us to uh to
operate our system because we do not
have to uh have to care about uh these
uh um
intricacies uh as data
scientists yeah
okay an open and simple question this
time um you mentioned that
standardization put you forward improved
your efficiency uh can you give maybe
three examples of what you your best
case for where where
standardization put you forward if you
remember okay yeah like one simple
example as said we had a lot of uh of
specific implementations or custom
proprietary implementations and now uh
we have moved to like the the machine
learning model is based so the call
model is completely implemented in py to
now we even uh in the last iteration we
had some uh uh custom implementations of
some optimizers but now we are 100% py
toor more or less um our custom model
but using the framework as as is as it
is as it is um then I I would say
something like uh the the move of us now
to snowflake is some form of
standardization because all of the um
the cubes this uh parket um
representations this is also very very
much uh a making of Our Own
and
um a third uh area of uh third one is
really standardization of data delivery
from the customer side yeah so in the
beginning each customer was able to send
his custom way of the data and each bu
was different and once we standard side
on the data side we could build data
quality monitoring a standardized UI
have basically now yeah model
evaluations across yeah 40 customers in
one go that all look similar um so this
is really and my adding on top of the
pie torch story yeah when we moved from
implementing our own algorithms with cor
C++ parts to py torch we suddenly have
been able to scale by using gpus because
some clever open source guys really
ported pytorch to do model training on
gpus which enabled us a factor of 10 in
increasing um the time that we need to
train models and that's still very much
key for us because more expensive yeah
that's the other thing no but the keys
really are if you go be beyond the week
of model training time you you lose
velocity because if it detect the bug it
takes another week yeah to retrain it
and if you move it down to one day again
you have much better iteration cyles and
this is really something that we could
never have built our own yeah um this
large scale Improvement and the pie
torch guy or the open source guys yeah
brilliant work we benefit from it by
adopting now standard technology that
has been developed in the open sof
world you have a question yes okay last
question what's your environmental
impact you do a lot of computing so
what's your environmental footprint so
uh if you like I this is not my
expertise but if you believe our our
slides from our upper management it is
uh
that it is environmental impact is is
one of our strong suits because we are a
supply chain company so uh like the the
the impact of bad planning for uh large
organiz retail organizations is is
massive like if we are flooding some
store with beer on end
that's there's the footprint putting it
again getting it there and uh putting it
back if we have over predictions the
customers are discarding and wasting
resources because they are just uh
sometimes throwing things away that have
been over ordered so uh environmental
impact is actually some something that
we are putting our on our flag as a very
strong point because we are really um
improving the uh
environmental impact or the the
environmental footprint of our customers
which is which are organizations U like
ERS orud larger than especially our team
of this product so we have the we
introduce Solution toies that's um the
second largest um supermarket chain in
in the UK with more than thousand stores
and once we have introduced our
automated system we reduced waste by
five to 10% on, stores with 40,000
products and I think this is the really
real world impact of course yeah you
have the compute resources but this is
then really and it goes down really to
reducing meat waste where if you think
it a little bit further it's really
killing animals for nothing so of course
that's not the marketing slide that I uh
provide to you but I think there um I
think we all have some real real world
impact
wonderful so uh yeah thanks zaa for the
great talk thanks for the questions and
answers and now we come to the
next uh now what's
next oops lightning talks lightning
talks right lightning talks is next
and let me just announce the lightning
talks and feel free to get another yeah
we have 30 seconds
just raise your hand and say beer then I
bring
some I'm raising a glass oh okay
so okay you have 60
seconds to let
[Music]
us all right
um high demand of drinks so we're going
to start with lightning talks in a
minute
this V to my talk
B
all
right
hop lightning lightning TS yeah all
um all right let's start with the
lightning talks we have three lightning
talks today one by wam a glimpse into
Cal reasoning with lmm I'm going to give
a lightning talk about python XEL
whether it's hell yes or hell no um not
spoiling anything and we have gang
talking about python bar camp in K so
uhan yeah it's getting a drink yeah
thank that's very good okay it's uh
you're up
now all right uh one one minute so game
yeah so we're getting ready for the
first lightning talk
and you
go
so
maybe one question who knows lightning
talks who doesn't Okay so lightning
talks is just like you can talk about 5
minutes about everything which is
basically appropriate uh but you have
exactly five minutes and there's no Q&A
afterwards yeah and the talk will end
after five minutes no matter what okay
here you go oh stop
stop four minutes now yeah uh before I
start I uh I want to share a very small
uh story
uh about blue yonder so it was
20145 I was working at the research
assistant K and I was part of very small
team Mr Institute mass and regul
technique and we were working on the
image processing algorithm for the
autonomous driving and we've started to
hear about this deep learning machine
learning and it was kind of a yeah first
try out to do it and then we hearing
about blue yonder who is not just for
years already selling the machine
learning Solutions but already hiring
some people and for us it was like a big
aha moment so thank you guys you're one
of the pioneers and uh yeah it's a
pleasure to be here today okay okay
great
so we are starting now my name is R I'm
a founder of black Foria and today let's
talk about the causal
reasoning so majority of the businesses
that we are having today whatever the
industries are they are dealing with
unstructured data yeah so and it's uh
representing about 80 90% so officially
it's 90% And we are talking about this
is the basically the data flow and on
the level of the data collection
processing yeah this is like the the
problematic area with the highest level
of complexity and however highest level
of the automation
required and if we are talking about the
llms how can we implement it here not
just to deal with the unstructured thata
but also to deal with with this Dynamics
because we're living in the big uh data
age and that is in motion we have two
opportunities basically we can continue
to fine tune our llm big foundational
model in order to deal with those uh
dynamics of the data but we have two
problems here cut of dates and the
catastrophic forgetting catastrophic
forgetting is the every single cycle of
Define tuning brings this um opportunity
negative opportunity that one day your
model will start forget some critical
parameters however another uh um way how
you can do it and this is majority of
the businesses they working on this
solution So-Cal rag retrieval augmented
generation this is the next slide we
will talk about it but at the begin uh
but essentially here are two issues
retrieval sensitivity which is basically
your retrieval system or the algorithm
which is very sensitive how it works and
it requires the know how how to do the
instruction tuning back to your llm this
is the Knowledge Management the one part
how it looks like you have your llm you
have your rock whatever the Corpus of
data you are dealing with and you are
connecting it yeah it could be
observation L experiment uh experimental
selection bias basically you have a quy
you need to have the causal model this
is a lot of machine learning people now
start to understand because all of the
processes are always different different
compliance different Domino you need a
caal model representing the process or
the data generation process and then
basically we have the llm whether it's
fine tune instruction tune it depends on
the business itself what we do at black
Foria we concentrating on the reasoning
basically con concentrating on two parts
to identify the cause effect pairs in
the data uh that the llm delivers
through the Rock and cross cross task
generalization so basically it's on this
slide on this side but in reality our
solution also part of the rock
system so why we need in general
reasoning so here it's two examples Chad
GPT I'm pretty sure all of you heard
about this and basically the in average
human intelligence human
capability SoCal the formal reasoning
it's logic just the logic so it's being
estimated so that the charp at it at its
best on different kind of the synthetic
data cannot achieve
40% we humans at the yeah let's say at
the average we are already more than
50% and this is a technical
representation how the llm are uh does
inference and this is all of our
capabilities as the humans because we
have sensory uh information ears uh eyes
and of course we are much more advanced
in terms of the
perception
and here you see um yeah maybe two
examples chpt and the best of
Germany uh Al Alpa by the way Jas I told
you you need to work with us this is not
good so uh two areas two uh benchmarks
Common Sense uh where the chpt gpt3
achieves
61% and um Al alha unfortunately only 11
this this is soal the chain of thoughts
um promp prompting technique and we are
talking about the F1 score and here's
the ground truth ground truth means so
that we are introducing the causal graph
uh which uh should help but in reality
we see it's only almost 50/50 chance to
get the accuracy so it's not acceptable
by the business basically no reasoning
in practice and yeah supervisor learning
still number one choice thank you very
much who very
good
yeah thanks a lot for the talk uh you
have 10 seconds left thank you
guys all right we come to the next
lightning talk which is actually by
myself um
so y thank
you so
see if
fits yep very well so okay can you do
the timer please
so and I will start now okay I this is a
at least a 10 minutes talk about python
Excel python in Excel so hell no ORS as
you know python is now part of excel so
you know me you know python Excel so
python Excel is actually nothing new
there has been Excel Wings around to
interact with Exel from python code
doing amazing speed ups and whatever so
this is not new but the very new thing
which is probably very hyped now is
python within Excel you can open Excel
and just type python in your Excel cell
and you don't need to set up an
envirment and this is basically not a
bad idea because so many customers of
all they really don't get how to set up
python environments and we have to I
don't know one solution to make it easy
for regular people to manage
environments if you don't do it on a
daily basis it's still like an ensemble
problem yeah so environments are black
magic to many so the idea we have Excel
here you can just like insert python use
use some data put it there and then you
have this atpy function and you can
create you can create a a pandas data
frame yeah as you already see you have
like a beautiful code completion here
it's like writing text but and the
people are actually like uh it's it's
it's you can do directly analysis on the
data you have in your Excel sheet with
pandas pandas is built in as matplot lip
you can write a lot of code if you watch
what people suggest on YouTube you can
yeah J GTP can write the code for you
you just put it here and uh so yeah you
see there's batteries included pandas
mlo lip stats models numi C
so okay um so I was said okay um
technically this might be impressive and
it was done by Microsoft and Anaconda
actually um you can do more so there's H
this is everything that I mentioned is
imported here and you have access to a
data frame uh but actually like it has
like a very unique calculation logic so
if you have a data frame here you can
reference it from from from left to
right and from top down which is great
because if you want to reference refence
it over there it will be not known that
is pretty strange and this is like how I
feel about these things but I said okay
let's not just ask my bubble so I asked
Twitter like not only my Twitter bubble
so like a bubble so hey python XEL what
do you think I did that in August wi was
basically new and basically I I was
really concerned like hell yes and
Heaven is the majority and there seems
only be like 177% of people said hell no
and I can now spoil I'm definitely with
the hell no people why um because
although this enables a lot of people
like python Exel like that's the verdict
so this is like how the distribution of
the sizes of the communities of
programming languages so there's like
15.7 million python users estimated
that's from statista and Exel basically
in a know
70 70 7050 750 million ion Excel users
who are out there who can now also be
python users so this is good news for
python as you can see because we're now
terminating everyone like yeah but then
Python and Exel you have to see yeah
it's okay yeah I mean this is ugly I
mean you all know there's VBA code
there's macros in EXO yeah there's all
this like Shadow it going on already and
it's a big mess once you start a data
project is a big mess with all these
tools and it's it's not really good I
don't see any reason this is a bit
better to maintain than the other crap
we had before I'm sorry yeah and
anything beyond simple yeah I mean I
don't I don't I think it's okay to
enable users who cannot would just want
to do some quick quick and dirty
analysis within exle sheet I don't mind
that I think that's a great feature but
anything beyond simple is basically
Legacy once you put push enter and
there's more yeah but it works on my
axle fire you will see that and you have
basically zero re usability yeah and
there's more danger zones because what
about type safety I mean there's pandas
pandas will just pass the data and Exel
users are very sensitive to data quality
and missing data and how will we handle
that and also like security issues
because actually python code is not
executed locally it runs in a Microsoft
cloud so and yeah so this is probably
not even admissible for many and uh yeah
debugging I think debugging will be
really fun with an Exel uh python in
Excel because Excel sheets debugging is
already fun and as I mentioned yeah it
does not offer any solution for FAL data
problems and I want to uh close to uh
the 70 50 million Excel users now able
to use Python with good luck thank
you and this brings us to our next
lightning talk so where are you yeah
lightning talks okay are you ready all
right you go and you also
need
this okay um I don't prepar any slides
yet because uh we we introduced the
python bam cut through on Friday so it's
quite few days where we announced but
I'm happy to uh introduce to you the uh
python bham culture will um take place
at the dhbv which is only about 700 M uh
in this direction and it will take part
on 23rd and 24th of March and I'd like
to uh invite you to uh this SP Camp
there will be a lot of topics um in in
about Pon and some something like this
do you know uh the format B Camp you
already uh take place in one maybe a
little a little confused uh what a b
Camp is a b Camp is a lot is a place
where the topics are generated by the
group um we are getting together and uh
choosing and planning our uh sessions um
at these days yeah and so I'd like to
invite you we will be there and um the
organizers are um a friend of mine
living in mbor and me
yeah um I will be very nice if you like
to join us thank
[Applause]
you
all right thank you and really thanks
for organizing um I'm really happy to
see python bar cam happening in
Carro
[Music]
and so uh yes final announcements so oh
yes final announcements without any
okay bye
bye byebye hello projector hello
so
yes okay uh where were we we were here
right yeah so uh yes if you haven't we
have a LinkedIn group also for
announcements and and stuff and uh we
have a call for speakers so if you did
you like the talks
today all right so this can be your
stage as well to talk about your topics
anything anything you want to share uh
don't be afraid to see like it's a
really uh forgiving funny and welcoming
community and I think if you really want
to learn something give a talk about it
and you would be surprised how many
Renown speakers basically give talks
about something they're just learning
and you wouldn't notice from their talks
yeah also if you want to contribute a
five minute Landing talks okay just go
to there's a web form you can just throw
your ideas there and we will get back to
you immediately the next part data will
be in heidleberg and the at the 5th of
December at heidleberg Material formerly
known as heidleberg cement but cement is
uh probably not so fashionable anymore
so it's my mat here is now um so um yeah
so see you there and also yeah and then
24th of January I um yeah um your turn
also uh give us feedback contribute
lightning talk or talks yeah um you can
host and sponsor us rate is in made on
meet up out if you have any questions uh
and yeah thanks to to Sebastian and
Peter for hosting and bl of course
thanks to the speakers Johannes and uh
you want us Noob Jakob sorry I'm sorry
not good names yeah and yeah and I think
that's that's it so yeah oh yeah here oh
good okay and Kevin for video Ops of
course and Sebastian for Q&A I didn't
know that when I put the slide so XX so
yeah and that's that's it welcome thank
[Applause]
you so thanks also from outside so